suppose marketing experts have
determined the relationship between the
selling price of an item and the cost of
an item can be represented by the linear
equation
q is equal to negative 30 s
plus 800 where q is the quantity sold in
a year and s is the selling price
if the cost to produce the item is
twenty dollars so the cost to produce an
item is twenty dollars what is the
selling price that optimizes the yearly
yearly profit so what's the profit going
to be so let me write this down so our
yearly profit is going to be the
quantity is going to be the quantity
that we sell in a year it's going to be
the quantity that we sell in a year
times
times the price that we sell it at
price times the price that we sell it at
minus the cost of us actually producing
that item in this case they tell us it
is 20
so for example if we sell two items if q
is two and we sell them for twenty five
dollars we're going to make five dollars
on each item because it costs each of
them cost us five twenty dollars to
produce so 25 minus 20 will be five if
we sell two items at that price it'll be
two times five or we'll have a profit of
ten dollars so what how can we figure
out how to maximize this profit well
they gave us the quantity as a function
of selling price so we could we could
express the entire profit as a function
of selling price so we could say
we can substitute q
is equal to negative 30 s plus 800
right over
right over here and let's be very clear
what this is telling us this is telling
us that if the selling price
increases then this will become a larger
negative number so we're going to sell
fewer we're going to sell a smaller
quantity and actually if you believe
this and if you actually made the
selling price zero if you may if you
just gave away this product it tells us
that we would sell at most 800 so it
might not be a perfect model but let's
just use this for you know some
marketing experts have told us this so
let's just use it
so if we substitute negative 30 s
plus 800 for q
we get negative 30 s
plus 800
times s minus 20
times
i'm just in a different shade of yellow
times s
minus 20. this is profit as a function
of selling price and now we can just let
me be very careful here let me be very
clear this is this is q right here and
so this whole thing is q want to make
sure we're multiplying this whole
expression times this entire expression
right over there and so let's do that so
this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to negative 30
so let me just distribute it out this is
going to be negative 30s
times s minus 20 times this whole thing
we're just taking this whole term we're
first multiplying it times negative 30s
and then we're going to take this whole
term and then multiply it by 800 s minus
20. and so this gives us this is equal
to negative 30 s times s we have to
distribute again
negative 30
s squared negative 30 s times negative
20 is going to be positive
positive 6
positive 600
s
and then we have 800 times s so that's
plus 800 s and then 800 times negative
twenty so that is negative eight times
two is sixteen and we have one two three
zeros one two three zeros and if we
simplify we can add these two terms
right over here we get negative 30 s
squared plus
1400 s
minus 16 000. so we now we've now
expressed we've now expressed our profit
as a function of selling price and this
is actually going to be a downward
opening parabola and we can tell that
because the the coefficient on the
second degree term on the quadratic term
is negative so if we were to graph this
if we were to graph this
so over here let me draw a better graph
than that
over here this axis right here is going
to be the selling price and this is
profit which is a function of selling
price this graph right this equation
right over here is going to look like
this is going to look something like
this we already saw the selling price
let me write just write it this way
so let me just
it's going to look something like this
i don't know what the exact equation is
going to look like but it's going to be
downward opening and what we want to do
is maximize the profit we want to find
this maximum point right over here you
could do it with calculus if you if you
had calculus at your at your at your
fingertips or you could just recognize
this is the vertex of the parabola and
you could you could figure out the
vertex by putting in vertex form but the
fastest way is to just know that the
normally the x-coordinate or the
s-coordinate the s-coordinate of the
vertex is going to be negative b
over 2a
and if we want to figure out what
negative b over 2a is we just take the
this is the b right over here so it's
negative b so it's negative 1400
over
2a
over 2 times
negative 30 which is equal to
negative 1400
over
negative 60. negatives cancel out we
could divide the numerator and the
denominator by 10. so this is the same
thing as 140
over 6. we can divide the numerator and
denominator by 3. sorry by by uh by 2
and you get 70
you get 70 over
3 and then we can just divide that so 3
goes into 70 3 goes into 7 2 times 2
times 3 is 6.
subtract you get a difference of 1 bring
down the 0 3 goes into 10 3 times 3
times 3 is 9 subtract you have bring
down you get a 1. now we're in the
decimals we bring down another zero
becomes a 10 again 3 goes into 10 three
times i think you see where this is
going it's 23.3
repeating times it'll just if we just
keep doing this we're just getting more
and more and more threes
or if we just wanted to round to the
nearest penny since we're talking about
selling something
this optimal profit this optimal profit
will happen at a selling price of twenty
three dollars and thirty
twenty three dollars and thirty three
cents that will optimize the yearly
profit